my name is Kate Roberts I'm vice
president of population Services
International also the founder of youth
aids and 5 and alive our child survival
program as kind of my role with the
World Economic Forum I'm a young global
leader and I'm also a founding curator
of the young global shapers in
Washington DC's health I am particularly
amazed at the launch of the shapers
switch professor Schwab and Archbishop
Desmond Tutu did at our plenary launcher
of doubles this year the shapers have
taken Davos by storm and for me that is
extremely important because the reason I
do this three billion people live in
poverty a lot of those people are young
people and young leaders today seem to
have the solutions and I'm impressed
with how the shapers here at Davos are
embracing these social issues and
finding creative solutions to solve them
so watch out for the shapers are there
going to change the world